and and the the this task was in
deciding who we should nominate and
honor tonight as our Lifetime
Achievement Award winner and the process
to nominate and call-up Ray Dalio was
was very straightforward I mean we
looked at the number of possible
candidates and given the people that we
had nominated and honored in the past it
was just a standout to the point of
almost oversight that we we hadn't
brought in ray earlier if you if you
look at what he has done in terms of
contributing to the industry its
outstanding
he is probably more responsible than any
single individual for getting
institutions into the hedge fund
business now when you think of it the
way hedge fund started what they were
where they're going now by the end of
next year it's estimated that 80 percent
of assets going into hedge funds will be
institutional assets and the guy who
laid the foundation for that is Ray
value he also has been unique in the
manner in which he goes about making
decisions operating and what he calls
stress testing which essentially is he's
pretty sure he knows what he's doing and
Lord knows he's built Bridgewater into
the biggest hedge fund around so
obviously he's gotten a few things right
but he's careful enough to do what he
calls stress testing well his ideas
where he will engage in conversation to
the point of confrontation with his own
staffers to determine is this the right
way to go is this the best thing to do
so you've got a combination of a man who
has introduced institutions to the hedge
fund industry and also been a great
manager in getting the process to where
it is now so with that I'd like to bring
up Ray Dalio receiving a lifetime of
achievement award is
somewhat of a mixed blessing it's I'm on
the one hand extremely honored when I
think of all the terrific people in the
industry I think really hedge fund
people around the world are some of the
smartest people I've ever met in my life
and to be able to receive this award
particularly over a lifetime a lifetime
I think people get to know what you're
like and so when I think about the
people who are here and the the pleasure
that I've had to work with some of them
too many people to name I'm sure I
defend people and I think about the
people that I've had to also not only
the clients people I work with it's
really it's really a treat and on
somewhat an undeserved treat because I'm
the one who's standing up here and they
are really the ones who make this
possible so I'm very pleased about that
on the other hand I understand that
Lifetime Achievement Awards come late in
your career and I'm just beginning so I
don't think that you know it's a little
bit not at the end of my career so I'm
I'm a little bit disappointed about that
part of it also there's an aspect to
this which I'm not I've been so used to
being the anti-establishment
that it's a little bit odd to be up here
and be considered you know part of the
establishment or of the establishment
it's something that I haven't gotten
used to and I gets me a little bit
nervous too because I've honestly when
you get an award like this I guarantee
you that I'm really not as good as they
say that I am the mistakes have been
more important to me I've honestly Lee
Iacocca said it's it's easier to to
survive your failures than to survive
your successes and I think that that's
true when when you think about the
mistakes and the benefits of the
mistakes and how you learn I know myself
it's fear of failure that has been the
main
main driver of the greatest improvements
that we've ever had have been when we've
had the more challenging times that
makes you dig harder you learn from that
that's the better thing so I've it's
been a tremendous mixed blessing in
order to be up here but I there's been a
lot of talk about Bridgewater's culture
and I thought I would just say a few
words about what that is and why
Bridgewater has been special and I'm
going to take that opportunity I have a
clicker I don't have a clicker you say a
few words about okay I think the magic
formula for success of the business any
business is people in culture people say
what did you do to be successful how did
you construct portfolios how did you get
the deep knowledge I think the most
important ingredients are people and and
culture culture is values and the living
those values out in a way every day
so people so what do I mean by great
people I think the most important
qualities of people are three qualities
are character common sense and
creativity and the most important
quality is values you know we interview
people most companies look for skills
there are three things I think that make
up an individual there are their values
those are the things that draw people
together over a people over a period of
time whether you have a happy marriage
or though the best friends that you're
ever going to have or the people are
going to have the same values those are
the core most important ingredients then
there are abilities
natural abilities the ability to do math
or some people are naturally talents in
art we're given a certain ability
certain set of abilities and skills
skills are the things that I think most
companies make the mistake of putting
number one they'll ask different people
what are your skills did you do that job
before but they'll never ask them
questions like why do you work why do
you work for example yeah when we hum
when we hire people the most important
question is values well why do you work
if you're interested in working for
money you don't belong at Bridgewater if
you're interested in working for money
and status you don't belong at
Bridgewater we want people who live out
this culture
in which we deal with create a community
so this community these are the words
that are essential to the process we
have to have group values if you don't
talk about the values and the people
that you're working with how do you know
you have those values so when I look at
we've been doing this now for 35 years
35 years is a testament to the character
of the people who are doing that work so
35 years
you can tell what types of qualities
they have if they're doing it for money
there's a time where money there's a
choice between money and excellence and
you have to I think have those kinds of
values those deep values so you have to
have those group values one of the most
overriding value for us is truth and we
talk about the debate to get a truth so
you hit might hear that Bridgewater is a
very tough place to be and those that
truth through this debate process is the
thing that makes us better and that
truth sometimes has to include things
like things that you're not good at what
your weaknesses are I don't think that
there's a problem if people have
weaknesses and they know they have
weaknesses the greatest barrier that
people have in their own personal
evolution is not understanding their
weaknesses and running into them all the
time so we have a process which is a non
egotistical process of trying to get at
the truth
we have radical transparency to get at
the truth for example you can't talk
about anybody without that person being
in the room they're almost all of our
meetings are taped so anybody in the
company can listen to them through that
radical transparency because that's
produces an idea meritocracy and
excellence that's that's what we try for
that's excellence is not about money
Stradivarius built beautiful violins not
because he thought that they would be
more profitable to sell an expensive
Stradivarius violin there's a sense of
beauty and the people in
operation have to have that sense of
beauty the sense of beauty in terms of
the investment process the sense of
beauty in terms of every aspect client
service every aspect has to be that and
we appreciate each other and we fight
with each other in order to try to be
better and that's what creates community
you have to have a community I believe
that a community is a place where people
care deeply because they share those
same values and so we have to have a
certain type of community that in which
we care about each other we share each
other's lives and we get better together